hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me anna jones aisha hazarika and andrew
pierce are here to look back at the
biggest stories at the past seven days
so what were your top stories then this
week the car crash that was david
cameron's honors this which was the
story that just kept giving and giving
and off the back of that honors as well
for the labor party with jeremy corbyn
nominating Shami chakravarti and also
are very very difficult hustings for the
labor party this week which was more
pantomime than political debate okay
well more on those and all the other top
stories in a second but first let's get
a taste of what week was all about Bank
of England's cut interest rates to an
historic low of just one quarter of a
percent as it tries to keep the economy
stable a woman was killed and five
others injured by a man armed with a
knife in central London it came on the
same day that the Metropolitan Police
unveiled its new tactics to deal with
terrorism Dame Lord God art became the
third chairwoman of the inquiry into
child sex abuse to leave the post the
Home Secretary says the review will not
be abandoned there was controversy over
David Cameron's choices for his
resignation honors following his
departure from number 10 the funeral was
held for father Jacques MLB priest
murdered in france by sympathizers at
the self-styled islamic state as a lucky
escape for passengers on board this
plane which crashed landed in Dubai the
crew evacuated the aircraft just before
it exploded into flames and in Rio there
were scuffles as protesters demonstrated
along the route of the Olympic torch as
it made its way to the city ahead of the
start of the games
so it's a very busy Newsweek then so
what sticks out for you I do you think
the resignation honest list has been a
disaster for David Cameron his legacy
now will be taking us out of your
opinion which I'm thrilled about of
course but he's not a customer's job and
have completely toxic resignation honest
which confirms all the things a lot of
us have been saying that the Chum upgra
see the privileged elite at the heart of
the number ten machine all his public
schooled educated makes it got Obie
ECB's knighthoods which fact that they
didn't deserve and I'm sure is about
payment experimented a good job telling
mrs. Cameron what shoes to wear and what
frocks to wear and what to do there did
she really deserve an OBE a lot of not
the first Prime Minister of course to
honor some of their friends and allies
it's nice to clone interest I received
an MBE earlier this year for services
she worked Harriet Harman at least a
dame hood baronet Baroness or even the
free tonight bring that's all I know but
I think there's a serious issue look I
think the honor system should be there
to really honor people work very hard
such as myself but also there's a whole
thing about making the honor system or
flat the people's honors recognizing
people all across the country that's
done really good public service and that
kind of thing and I'm afraid this list
which as Andrew said is all about the
chakra see and has the whiff of
inappropriate donors as well it really
tarnishes what should be a you know a
good thing okay let's move on to another
big story of the week and the Bank of
England took the interest rate this week
to a new low of just not point two five
percent it was the first time it's moved
since 2009 with the bank warning that it
was needed to head off a recession well
here's our economics editor at Conway
breaking free of the recession trap
today the Bank of England unveiled its
most radical stimulus package since the
height of the financial crisis record
cuts in interest rates record amounts of
cash pumped into the economy and all to
protect Britain from the economic
slowdown it foresees after the
referendum
we're helping this economy respond to a
change a change in the relationship with
Europe and the rest of the world in as
an effective way as possible and we're
not waiting I think the key thing is
that we're not waiting to see a sharp
increase in unemployment to see an
actual downturn in activity before we
have the proof on the ground that we
should have acted before no we're acting
to minimize those risks to lean against
it to improve the prospects of this
adjustment to make this a success to get
a sense of how historic this moment is
have a look at this this is official
bank rate all the way from 1694 to today
it has never been as low as it is now
but as well as that the bank is doing
more a 100 billion pound system the term
funding scheme to encourage banks to
pass on the rate cut 10 billion pounds
which will be spent on corporate debt
and another 60 billion pounds spent on
government bonds what economists call
quantitative easing to give you an idea
of the scale that's more than twice the
amount of notes and coins sloshing
around the country the bank's plan is to
kick-start the economy speeding up
spending and growth in the coming months
that may mean another interest rate cut
in a few months time so another cart in
the interest rate to a new historic low
pass another package of measures to
inject more money into the economy
necessary do you think or or an
overreaction I think it is the right
thing to do for the Bank of England to
meet this sort of intervention now quite
soon after the decision to leave the
European Union I don't think it's kind
of hysterical but i think it's a it's a
short-term monetary or fiscal sort of
stimulus which is important but the
question evan is now saying is this is
going to be matched with what happens at
the budget and people will want a kind
of a proper sort of fiscal stimulus from
from philip hammond because i think
people are are worried about what's
going to happen to the economy
post-break said it doesn't mean that
we've got to be awfully scared or
scaremonger but i think they felt it was
the right decision now to make a kind of
short-term intervention just get more
money into the economy
get people spending one I think that's
the right thing to do it's only this
going to be passed on to the consumer
big question mark well the banks and
building societies cut interest rates to
the custom have to measure to try to
well there's no excuse of banks annuity
that banks have any excuse to ignore
ignore and not do the right thing their
lows for very good reason and part of me
thinks it's a bit rich for Carney to be
talking in this measured way there's no
need to panic about Briggs it when he
and the chance of the extender talked
down the economy again and again so no
wonder lots of money left bank accounts
and burnside gets because people
panicked and put it under the mat and
yet they have had to slash their growth
forecasts I think they yeah but the be
back in one year it's quite low but back
by the time about twenty eighty pretty
close to where we were before the
referendum anger there is some financial
uncertainty there was some certainty for
decision breaks it there there will be
some uncertainty I actually think Mark
Carney has done quite a good job of just
trying to kind of steady the ship a bit
and I actually thought was kind of
interventions really like in the hours
after the the decision to leave that you
to say look you know we're gonna be here
to sort of calm the markets you know
give a sense of reassurance I think he's
done quite a good job on that okay well
let's move on now and we're going to
move on to our gap of the week now do
you remember that feeling when you're at
school and forgot hand in your homework
never happened to me of course well
perhaps that's how would be you keep
leader stephen wolf felt when he missed
the deadline for his application to take
part in the context contest well now
while you're missed homework might have
landed you into trouble with the teacher
mr. Worf's exclusion has triggered an
all-out civil war in his own party and
what do you make of this I mean they use
17 minutes yes application petigura
matter you do pay it was an excuse to
kick kick him off the ballot paper
because he's Nigel Farage geez Candida
that and you keep his rhythm with
internal dispute Suzanne Evans who to
the popular choice for many to be the
leader she can't even run because she's
been suspended and lot of people think
the suspension was designed to keep her
off the ballot paper and now there's a
move to get the entire national
executive committee of the UK suspended
so the whole contest is in the melting
pot what is going on with these major
political party just feel something
better about the little jacket it's the
only Bo comfort well yes but a new kit
were on the right side of the argument
they won the brexit argument didn't they
the vote went in their direction so is
it surprised at their terms what's
really interesting is that a lot of
commentators see as much as a big figure
like Nigel Farage was sort of derided
and ridiculed he actually sort of held
you Kip together in as much of a
functional way as that party can exist
in his kind of sudden departure I sort
through in the party indicates but I
suspect that you Kip as we know it has
kind of reached the end of its current
existing life but there will be a new
successor to you kit because I suspect
Aaron banks will want to continue his
project and he's going to come after
those labor seats in the northern
heartlands well that was our gap of the
week don't forget you can send us in
your nominations as well using the
hashtag W in are now following several
terror attacks in Europe police here
unveiled new tactics to try to stop
incidents our home affairs correspondent
my wire reports on patrol along the
Thames the new face of armed policing
highly trained counterterrorism
specialists their capabilities on show
for the cameras
but this is more than a sleek PR
exercise by Scotland Yard it marks a
shift in tactics policing many more
highly visible armed officers at key
locations across the capital to counter
the growing threat of terrorist attacks
these are the specialist firearms
officers who are trained to push forward
to confront any attackers head on their
equipment is certainly eye-catching one
officer face covered because of the
highly sensitive nature of his work
acknowledges the site of armed teams
racing through London on these off-road
bikes might raise a few eyebrows but
they could he believes prove vital in
reaching the scene of an attack quickly
the first of these newly trained
firearms teams are already operating in
the capital and the public can expect to
see many more while the terror threat
remains severe
so incredibly dramatic pictures of
defined them reassuring or a little bit
frightening I mean I think they are
designed to try and give some comfort to
the public that the police and the
security services are really doing
everything they can and they're taking
as many sort of structural solutions as
possible more armed officers obviously
we've seen the kind of presence on the
on the thames but the truth is we all
know that it's very hard to stop a
terrorist attack it can only just take
one person doesn't have to be in London
it could be somewhere where we're not
expecting it to happen so it is a hard
situation I think the Cirque you know
the police and the security services
actually do a great job I think they
intercept and foil so many things we
never hear about but the public are wide
because we all know something probably
is going to happen at some point well
yes aunt is the point as you raise it
there that the armed police aren't
necessarily going to prevent a terror
attack its intelligence it's really like
to make little difference and we're
pretty sure that they've done a pretty
good job so far but this is all about PR
it's all about protecting outwards there
are record numbers of people coming to
Britain at the moment because the pound
is lower lots of tourists here so it's
not just about the domestic audience II
tried to reassure it it's these images
will be relayed all around the world and
that would be reassuring the people
might think oh it's London that have you
safe because France has been attacked
Germany's been attacked but at the end
of day and a lunatic with a knife can
still this will make no difference ok
time now for a quick quiz for you now
can you tell me why one piece of medical
advice might now be a little long in the
tooth oh yes Oh Andrew thinks he knows I
do I will find out of the break you
always notice
welcome back to week in review with me
anna jones i'm joined by aisha hazarika
a former labour advisor and comedian
whose current show is tales from the
pink bus and and repairs consultant
editor of the damn i'm sorry i'll say
labeled item comedian the two things
naturally go together [ __ ] okay sorry
he just nails really hear the moment
let's say for all politics labor at the
moment where it's be unkind yeah it's
not a first into the country let's be
honest is rattling and reveling in it so
painful that one to Kevin's gone off I'm
gonna I gotta drag you back to a yes I'm
afraid because before the break we did
ask which piece of medical advice might
now be a little long in the tooth thank
you get the dentist this week I'm quite
cross flossing according to research in
America is no good at getting rid of
plaque don't listen carry on well that's
what my hygienist did say you're
absolutely right is flossing your teeth
did you know that I am so glad here
because i always have massive guilt
about my lack of flossing and i find it
really hard to do as well it's just a
complete nitrous I feel really that's a
very useful piece of health information
yes it has been the recommendation of
dentists but for many years but one
leading practitioner has said there's
only weak evidence that it works this is
Professor Damian walmsley from
Birmingham University who says that more
studies are needed and people should use
interdental brushes to keep their teeth
my spleen what was that include football
manager called who was with the are you
to raise a gentleman he had had a lot of
food traps he would definitely have to
use dental floss what was his name goran
eriksson cuz it wasn't a fence about
football yeah it's tough loss yes sorry
punch in bars yes I imagine that you do
know a lot about that I will this week a
bartender took an unusual step to
protect the art of conversation skies
technology correspondent Tom cheshire
went to meet it
smartphones tend to distract us from
life's great pleasures and a drink is no
exception but of all the gin joints in
all the world this one has taken extreme
measures not by banning phones but by
blocking their signal outside this part
in hope I've got lots of mobile
reception oodles in fact but as I go in
rather terrifyingly the bars are
starting to vanish the owner was
inspired by a 19th century physicist
Michael Faraday Faraday cage is a tin
box at in boxers prevent signals from
coming in it's illegal to lock a signal
but not stop a signal so we can put
jammer in I just want people to enjoy
their night out in my bar without being
interrupted by their phones so rather
than ask them not to use their phones I
stopped their phones working still the
law is slightly unclear on blocking
phones jamming them using electronic
devices which this bar isn't doing is
certainly illegal but an off calm
spokesperson told Sky News unlike
jammers Faraday cages don't proactively
cause interference although they do
interfere with mobile reception we would
always recommend people seek legal
advice if they are unsure or than
installation breaches wireless
telegraphy lord but here at least it
seems 19th century technology is helping
solve a very 21st century problem so a
good idea to block your phone signal in
a bar or would that send you into
nervous what some of my mates to be
thrilled because my phone rings a lot I
would absolutely hate it I think it
would be terrible you'd have to actually
talk to your partner because I normally
go out for like drinks my friends and
we're all like just on Twitter the whole
time not communicating with each other
which I mean it is really bad and then
the relationship is called phubbing
isn't it when you sort of you know on
your phone the whole time but I think
people are getting quite sick of their
partners and their friends just being
like glued to their screen and there's
this whole thing about being in the
moment and sort of mindfulness and sort
of like really focusing on what you're
doing but after it would do my head in I
know that bara chi it's a very nice bar
and I've been in it before but I hadn't
realized that they'd put that device it
is easy why they put it no no no no
because I'm quite good at churches put
my phone back in my pocket and only if
it vibrates do I go house
I said to it okay we're going to move on
now to the newspapers and your choice of
top stories from this week and Andrew
we're going to start with you first of
all and this is a bad a controversial a
court decision over a drug isn't ya know
this is the High Court has told the NHS
they must prescribe this drug called
prep PR EP this is for to stop people
getting HIV you have to take it every
day and it costs five thousand pounds a
year but the NHS is a gas and I share
their horror because this is going to
put at risk thirteen other treatments
such as drugs for children with cystic
fibrosis to help and breathe and I'd say
children with cystic fibrosis pensioners
with cataracts their their treatments
will be affected too they don't have a
lifestyle choice here there's no option
if you losing your sight but this
druggist is primarily owned two gay men
to stop them getting HIV there's a
simple way to stop getting HIV practice
safe sex and condoms provided free on
the NHS you do not need to do this we do
not need to indulge the gay community
anymore I speak as a game at it outrages
me we're going down this route see I've
got a different view I think it's really
important for the NHS to keep em looking
to sort of pioneer new drugs and you
always I mean there's always finite
resources and the NHS that is the kind
of politics and the economics of the NHS
and you can always say look in the
sliding scale of who is the most
deserving but I think it is really
important if there is a new drug out
there to allow people to have the chance
to use it and actually often over time
these costs do go down as well from from
the drug companies tell that to the Leo
the older person who cannot have their
cataract operation and then is
restricted to their home sometimes NHS
have told people survium got enough
money weapon to ration it wear dark
glasses it's insulting where people have
been paying into the system when gays do
have a lifestyle choice they don't need
to take this drug what if they forget to
take it anyway so that's 5,000 pounds
down the drain just be careful and don't
expect the NHS to pick up the bill for
your for your sexual gratification okay
let's move on to Asia to your first
newspaper choice of the week I think
it's a Donald Trump I'm making headlines
once again once again every week we're
like I mean I haven't another we
dominated by a man who looks like a
whatsit yes we are actually
so um President Obama has made a big
intervention and has said that he does
believe that Donald Trump is just
completely unfit to haul the office of
President of the United States it's
largely driven by the attacks he has
made on the parents of a Muslim soldier
who was killed and he launched a massive
attack on them and attention we were
just having this discussion about you
know are the wheels coming off the kind
of Trump jugger naught and I have to say
I don't think they are and on this
specific about this couple they stood
before the Democratic convention they
talked about that their son who died in
afghanistan or iraq the iraqi was and
Trump pointed out that the mother never
said anything and he said that's because
she can't because she's a Muslim now
suggested that suggests now of course
the family sake notes because she was
too distraught but he's cleverly tapped
into the view that a lot of people will
say I bet that's why because cause a lot
of Muslim women are expected to stand
back can't go in the same entrance of
the mosque as the man and and he knows a
lot of people out in the great unwashed
not in the chattering class Washington
political belt will agree with what he
said okay let's move on ayesha to your
newspaper your second story that you've
picked out about a tower in Brighton so
this is a very big tarrant Brighton lots
of people are annoyed about because they
think it's not very pretty it's sort of
look I think it looks like a really
massive futuristic sort of span a
stairlift kind of thing it's like a big
thing which is not honest Turkish this
is doing that s it kind of moves up
quite and slowly and you're meant to get
these beautiful panoramic views of
Brighton but people are very cross about
it they absolutely hate I kind of
imagined probably once you get up there
it's probably quite fun and everyone
quite likes going on the London Eye and
seeing things my height but the locals
are not very happy with their own I've
got great friends there and it's slap
bang in the middle of the promenade
nobody remembers being consulted about
it it's five hundred and twenty eight
feet high and if you're open to those
fantastic Regency properties behind it
it interview it completely ruins the
vista a lot of people said they hated
buildings they now end up loving so you
never know public opinion might change
me
who knows okay we're gonna move on now
thanks to take you through your
newspaper choices what about your ups
and downs then and we're going to start
off Andrey with you who's your worries
about warming story about the lottery so
the Davis family mum is in America
getting treatment for what she thinks is
cancer she gets the all-clear she brings
her daughter back comb it says I think I
feel good about this buy a lottery
ticket they bought a lot to get 60
1,000,000 and when I'm what a great
cheerful story and the girl for the
ex-boyfriend of the daughter is quoted
in the paper saying then he broke a tree
to say I really wish them well I pays
gonna try and get back green-eyed
monster here Nikoli it's 61 million
pounds out of money that's a lot of
money any thoughts what would you do
with it well have fun spending it oh
yeah definitely that's quite a party you
can come I don't know and I would you
like it I guess girl stimulus for all
the gin bars and like I streets and do a
lot of shopping basically okay well
we're gonna send the lottery winners up
then and who are you sending down this
weekend I love this directs and the new
scientist has got got research all these
fantastically healthy foods we eat so
coconut milk incredibly expensive kale
and blue bridge wider eve blueberries
saying actually eat them and treat them
as much as you like they're doing you
absolutely no good no better than before
so all this great health lobby has been
caught out yet again I mean a few weeks
ago you tow don't bother buying low fat
milk because it's no good for nothin
advisement oh it's like don't bother
flossing and just know you warn that's
great haiyan just say oranges and
brussel sprouts are just as good thanks
ft I'm that keen on that idea of
isolation baby shouts for really yes I'm
not a big fan of sprouts any we're going
to send superfoods down so only sure
what about you who you sending up I'm
sending up the mercury music awards
which were announced yesterday and it is
an absolutely brilliant list it's 12
albums and what's really great about it
it's such a vivid eclectic mix of music
and it has the sort of icons that you
think about like you know David Bowie's
on the list and radiohead but also it's
got a really diverse list it's got
Lauren mavala it's got lots of grime
artist as well so I think for the first
time and really cannot complete my time
oh I'm going to clean this channel later
it's not it so it's not but it's been I
think it shows the British music
industry is doing fantastically well
we're having a real kind of golden
moment across the globe okay and you've
got to go out and brine okay so we're
going to send mercury the victory Awards
up until using da self-service checkouts
this the these are like the bane of my
life basically and there has been a
study shown saying that a people are get
really confused about how to you should
spend most of time going excuse me
somebody help me like I could somebody
nobody understands how to work me to
sort of degree to be able to work it and
also people appear to be nicking stuff
even normally honest people apparently a
frustrating so hard to work out what's
happening you don't know if you've scans
are fitting on what's on the scales are
pretending instead instead of like
something expensive ons guys are bring a
cheaper thing on the way I have to say
I've Nick the odd carry bag yeah Oh
Andrew okay I think we should make like
a citizen's arrest likely television go
down this week wouldn't be the first
time in fact we're gonna send the
self-service checkouts down so thank you
very much indeed for taking us through
those don't forgetting you can send us
your nominations as well using hashtag w
in our so thank you both very much
indeed for joining us for our review of
the week we'll be back with plenty more
next week but for now it's goodbye from
them good bye bye and it's goodbye from
me